foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's presentation
accelerate your research with luminex's
xmap and Teleflex the xmap technology
you trust plus the versatility you need
I'm Sheri Dunbar and I'm the senior
director of scientific Affairs programs
for luminex and I'm very excited to have
the privilege of speaking to you today
about the xmap intelliflex instrument
which is the newest multiplexing
platform available from luminex
first let me take a moment to introduce
you to or reacquaint you with luminex
and review some of the key milestones in
the history of our company
the company began in 1995 with a 64 Plex
of color-coded microspheres and the
software to run them on a flow cytometer
but it was in 1999 that we shipped our
very first very own luminex 100 analyzer
complete with a full 100 Plex of bead
sets we called this the three fives
which meant that it was one-fifth the
size of a flow cytometer it was
one-fifth the price of a flow cytometer
but five times faster so this instant
instrument was specifically designed and
optimized for running multiplexed assays
using our xmap microspheres it was also
in 1999 that I joined the company and so
I've been able to experience all of our
growth and the advances of our
Technologies over the years
luminex Works closely with our partners
in Diagnostics and in research and it
was one of our diagnostic Partners who
achieved the first IBD cleared assay on
xmap technology I believe that this was
in 2001 and it was for HLA tissue typing
in 2005 we received IBD clearance for
our X tag cystic fibrosis assay and this
was the first multiplexed molecular test
for CF that was cleared for Diagnostic
use
in 2007 we've entered into the
infectious diseases Arena and received
IBD clearance for the first multiplexed
molecular test for Respiratory viruses
which was the x-tag respiratory viral
panel
the flex map 3D instrument came out in
2009 and it was a huge advancement in
x-map technology with the ability to now
analyze 500 different colored bead sets
at the same time in a single reaction
well
we then began to develop real-time PCR
applications and we received clearance
for our HSV-1 and 2 multiplexed
real-time PCR assay using the multi-code
isobase technology from origin
in 2013 the xtag gastrointestinal
pathogen panel became available for in
vitro Diagnostics and was the first
molecular Multiplex test for the
detection and differentiation of
bacterial viral and parasitic
gastrointestinal pathogens
in 2015 we launched our own sample to
answer cartridge based real-time PCR
instrument the Aries and with it the
Aries HSV-1 and 2 assay
then with our acquisition of nanosphere
we gain the ability to do higher Plex
sample to answer molecular testing and
could now offer both targeted and
syndromic Sample to answer assays in
2019 we went back to our roots with the
acquisition of the cytometry business
from millipor Sigma and we have several
flow cytometers for applications such as
cell counting basic cell viability and
cell Health analyzes and also Imaging
flow cytometers that add quantitative
microscopy Imaging for every cell that's
analyzed
of course 2020 marks the start of the
covid-19 pandemic and we were fortunate
to be one of the companies able to
provide diagnostic solutions for SARS
cov2 detection we developed eua
authorized nucleic acid assays for
detection of SARS cov2 on all of our
platforms and also a multi-antigen
serological assay for measuring
virus-specific itg
then in 2021 we launched our new x-map
intelliflex instrument which is what I'm
going to be speaking to you about today
but also in 2021 was another momentous
event which after 26 years in business
luminex was acquired by diasaurin so now
we are luminex a dinosaur company and
together with our new parents we're
really looking forward to all that we're
going to be able to achieve and what
we're going to be able to deliver to
Laboratories in the years to come
until the launch of intelliflex two flow
analyzers have really been the
workhorses of x-map Technology assays
the luminex 200 became available in 2007
and it was our first upgrade to that
original Lumax 100 analyzer the luminex
200 can Multiplex up to 100 assays in a
well and can read a 96 well plate in 45
minutes this is 12 800 results per hour
the flex map 3D came out in 2009 and
really Advanced the technology for the
high throughput laboratory it can run a
full 500 Plex of multiplexed feed assays
and through the Dual fluidics Pathways
it can process a 96 well plate in about
20 minutes it can also run 384 wall
plates and it can read a whole 384 well
plate in about 75 minutes
so with flex map 3D you can get 144 000
results per hour in 96 Wells or 153 600
tests per hour in the 384 well format
now in Teleflex
intelliflex Builds on the best of the
luminex 200 and the best of flex map 3D
but in a modern compact instrument
intelliflex has a very intuitive
software that has flexibility and allows
customization for your specific
workflows and even your preferred file
formats file formats are available that
are compatible with our partners
analytics software as well as other
common data analysis packages all of
this is intended to provide an overall
better user experience it's still
delivering the reliable sensitive and
high quality data that people have come
to know and expect from xmap technology
but now with a new second reporter
Channel you can simultaneously measure
two different parameters for each of
your analytes so therefore you can
essentially double the amount of data
that you get from the same number of
wells and Teleflex is based on three
main Concepts the high quality data and
note that the system is completely
compatible with the thousand plus assays
that are already available for x-map
technology from luminex and from all of
our partners the new dual reporter
capability which I'm going to share some
data about and examples about later in
the presentation and the flexibility to
customize the look and feel of the user
interface and the format of the data
output
before we dive into the data though I'd
like to spend a few minutes reviewing
key concepts of xmap technology that we
can build on as we learn about
intelliflex
let's start with some fast facts after
27 years xmap is certainly a proven
technology and we really are the world
leader when it comes to bead based
multiplexing at last count there are
more than 58 000 peer-reviewed
Publications that use xmap technology
and these references use xmap technology
products from luminex but also from all
of our partners in all of their xmap
products
over 20 000 instruments have been placed
so far in Laboratories around the world
and at last count more than 1300 rueo
assay kits have been developed and more
than 100 x-map based assays have
received five 10K clearances for
Diagnostic use but these stats increase
almost daily so I'm sure that this slide
is probably already out of date
so let's talk about some of the ways
xmap technology is used virtually any
binding event can be applied to the
microserior surface if there is a way to
capture an analyte and a way to detect
it you can run it on xmap technology and
this same technology works great for
both proteomic and genomic applications
common assay formats include the capture
sandwich immunoassay where a specific
capture antibody usually a monoclonal is
covalently coupled to the bead surface
and combined to the analyte in the
sample then a labeled detection antibody
can be used to quantify The Binding
events that have occurred on the
microsphere surface forming an analyte
sandwich
the competitive immunoassation in the
middle here is an assay format that we
typically use for small analytes and if
only one antibody is available
we can do this in two ways on the
microspheres as shown here we can use an
antibody coupled microsphere and a
labeled analyte to compete with that
analyte in the sample for binding to the
microsphere the signal decreases as the
amount of the unlabeled analyte in the
sample increases another way to do this
is to couple the analyte to the bead and
then use that to compete with the
analyte in the sample for binding to a
labeled detection antibody
the indirect assay format shown on the
right is used for serological tests
where a specific antigen is coupled to
the bead and then can be used to bind to
specific antibodies present in the
sample these captured antibodies can
then be detected and Quantified using a
reporter-labeled anti-immunoglobulin
detection antibody
x-map multiplexing has been used for
numerous applications in proteomics
including identification of secreted
proteins determining the mechanisms of
action in metabolic and enzymatic
Pathways drug monitoring looking at
protein protein interactions and many
others
on the nucleic acid side shown in the
bottom half we couple a capture probe
onto the bead and then we use a variety
of assay chemistries for Target
detection one of the most common assay
formats is direct hybridization of a
labeled PCR product the sequence
specific capture probe is covalently
coupled to the bead and used to capture
the Target that has been Amplified and
labeled from the original sample we also
have our magplex tag microspheres which
are pre-coupled with unique anti-tag
capture sequences
the assay chemistry whether it's PCR
primary extension or oligonucleotide
ligation serves to incorporate the
complementary tag sequence and the label
for detection into the nucleic acid
Target if it was present in the original
sample
the hybridization is so specific that it
can discriminate to the single
nucleotide level so it performs very
well for genotyping and even micro RNA
analysis and with the appropriate
standards and controls it can also be
quantitative or semi-quantitative and it
works really well for applications such
as gene expression analysis and
measuring copy number uh variation
here's an example of how x-map
multiplexing compares to other common
platforms and we'll use the analysis of
21 cytokines in 80 samples as our
example
as a compared to a single Plex
technology such as Eliza xmap allows you
to run all of your assays simultaneously
in solution with a small reaction volume
so you will use less sample and it will
take less time and less work to generate
results you will have a lower cost for
the reagents and the consumables plus
you'll generate more data and really
better data that I'm going to explain to
you further in a moment
if we're comparing to planar arrays
you're going to have a faster binding
kinetics because the beads are in
suspension and with a very high surface
to volume ratio that can provide better
sensitivity so to analyze 21 cytokines
from 80 samples you would need 42 96
well plates if you were using a single
Plex Elisa
if you were using a planar array system
you would need probably at least 396
wall plates if you could have up to 10
spots per well but with xmap technology
you only need one in the Publications
that are cited here you can read about
some studies where these investigators
compared the performance and the
workflows for different methods for
cytokine analysis
and there are links to these papers as
well on the luminex website
so let's talk about luminix's Partners
our partners have really taken the
technology to the next level and Beyond
as I mentioned at last count there were
over 1300 assays available as well as
custom assay capabilities and various
analysis software packages from
different luminex partners
our kit finder app shown on the left is
available on the luminex website and it
can help you find an already available
assay kit for your analytes and for your
species of Interest
some examples from our partners include
products from biorad biotechnie
Millipore Sigma and Therma Fisher and
these include Multiplex assay kits in
both 96 and 384 well formats as well as
custom assay services and software
packages for analyzing the data so here
I'd like to encourage you to check out
all of their websites to see all that's
available for xmap technology
now let's review how the detection works
on our flow analyzers the completed
assay that contains the multiplex beads
is aspirated into the sample cuvette in
a rapidly flowing fluid stream
hydrodynamic focusing confines the beads
to the center of the sheath fluid core
and sends the beads past the lasers one
at a time each bead is excited with the
red laser to measure the unique
combination of dies inside the bead
which identifies the bead region and
hence the specific assay that's being
measured on that bead the green laser
excites and measures the surface orange
fluorescence to quantify the amount of
analyte that has been bound to the
microsphere surface
so the instrument software calculates
the reporter signal on the microsphere
surface And the reporter die that's
present is correlated to the amount of
analyte that was present in the sample
the reporter die which we call rp1
excites at 532 nanometers and it
measures the emission at 565 to 585
nanometers
50 microspheres at least of each region
are individually interrogated the median
fluorescent intensity is calculated from
all of the events and that's what's
reported by the software and by taking
the median the effect of bead carryover
is eliminated because outliers are
excluded from the analysis as depicted
at this chart on the bottom right
so just to recap for each reaction we
typically measure a minimum of 50 beats
per set of each bead color or bead set
that is in the reaction we then
determine the median of this fluorescent
intensity that was measured for those
beads we call this value mfi and unlike
an Elisa where you're measuring the sum
of the signal in the well each beat is
measured as a replicate of the reaction
so for each well we are essentially
measuring 50 replicates per assay and
then reporting the median of those
measurements so the data are very robust
and the median ensures data integrity
the median really is the best statistic
to use because unlike the mean it cannot
be skewed by a few events that may have
been carried over from a previous well
okay so now that we've been through all
of these basics of luminex and xmap
Technology I think we're ready to dive
into the intelliflex in more detail
we have two models for intelliflex the
standard model which has much of the
same features that you're used to on
flexmath 3D such as the 500 Plex
capability a single green reporter laser
it's compatible with both 96well and 384
well plates but it also has an
additional decade of dynamic range so
now there's 5.5 logs of dynamic range in
the reporter one channel and with an
integrated PC and a touch screen it has
a really compact footprint as well as
Hardware features that make it really
easy to load and unload a plate
designed to be modular with components
that are easy to access for our field
service Engineers when they come to do
your preventative maintenance the second
option the drse model has all of this
plus a second reporter channel that
employs a violet laser this new reporter
channel has about 4.5 logs of dynamic
range and this model also has a side
eject plate carrier that makes it really
easy to connect to laboratory automation
systems
now let me describe the Optics in
intelliflex in the single reporter
system shown on the left we have our
Avalanche photodiodes or apds and our
doublet discriminator DD for bead
classification through the red laser the
532 nanometer green laser excites and
sends the reporter fluorescence to the
photomultiplier tube or PMT to measure
reporter 1 emission at about 565 to 585
nanometers and it will also send some
reporter signal to the extended dynamic
range or EDR detector so that the
reporter signal can still be Quantified
even if the PMT has reached saturation
in the Dual reporter model shown on the
right we have an additional 405
nanometer Violet laser that excites the
second reporter die and measures
emission at 421 to 441 nanometers in the
second photomultiplier 2.
okay as an example of intelliflex
performance I have some data that was
kindly provided by Therma Fisher this
chart shows the results for il-8 from
their 45 Plex probe cartiplex cytokine
panel you can see here on the left that
when the standard curves generated on
intelliflex were compared to the luminex
200 and the flex matte 3D instruments at
all of the possible calibration settings
or operating modes the results were
virtually identical the standard curves
are laying right on top of each other
and if you look on the right at the data
for a variety of different samples the
results were also very similar to that
on the classic xmap flow instruments
this will be important for those of you
who are already using an xmap instrument
and assays because you have all of the
settings that will provide you the
option of seeing the results and the mfi
values that you're used to seeing but as
well you can try some of the new data
acquisition modes that are only
available on intelliflex
so now let's talk about some
applications for intelliflex here's a
cartoon of a serological application
that we would use to measure antibody
response has been particularly useful
now in the time of coven as we've been
looking at antibody responses to
vaccines as well as natural infection so
just to remind you that in a single
reporter instrument if you were
interested at looking at different
antibody isotypes to a specific antigen
you would have to run two separate wells
in this example let's say we want to
measure IGG and IGA that is specific for
the green hexagon antigen so all of the
antibody isotypes that are present in
the sample are going to bind to the
antigen on that bead but we could only
detect one at a time
so in well one we can use a ficoerythrin
or PE labeled
anti-ig-g detection antibody and the red
laser would classify the bead set in
which antigen is being tested the green
laser measures that IGG that is bound to
the surface and is being detected with
that PE labeled
anti-immunoglobulin antibody okay but
what about IGA
so now you have to do a separate well so
you set up the identical reaction in the
second well but in this well we're going
to use a PE labeled
anti-iga detection antibody to detect
how much of the antigen specific IGA was
bound
so this is how we would typically do
this
okay but now with intelliflex it's a
whole new ball game because of the Dual
reporter option the Dual reporter gives
you the ability to measure two antigen
specific antibody isotypes in a sample
from only one well as before the antigen
is coupled to the microsphere and then
the microspheres are allowed to incubate
with the sample so all the antibodies in
the sample that recognize and combine to
that antigen are captured onto that
antigen coupled bead so whatever isotope
it is but in this example we can add a
PE labeled anti-igg detection antibody
and a brilliant Violet labeled anti-iga
detection antibody at the same time and
this allows measurement of both the
antigen specific IGG and antigen
specific IGA that's bound to the bead in
the same well at the same time
so here's some example data for Sarge
cov2 antibody responses where we used
our own x-map SARS cov2 multi-antigen
IGG kit but we substituted different
detection antibodies and different
reporters to be able to measure IGG and
IGM at the same time in our intelliflex
dual reporter instrument
three runs were performed in parallel
using the Dual reporter setting on
serial dilutions of positive serum in
panel a you see the iggpe signal when it
was the only detection antibody present
in the reaction and the background
levels in the reporter 2 or rp2 channel
in B you see the IGM super bright 436
signal when it was the only detection in
a body present with low less than 100
background level mfi in the reporter 1
or rp1 Channel and then in C you have
the responses when both detection
antibodies were present in the at the
same time in the same reaction which is
shown in the solid lines and then as
shown by overlaying this single reporter
data from A and B in the dotted lines
you can see that the results are nearly
identical
so this really showed that you can use
the two different reporter dies at the
same time in the same reaction without
any kind of interference between the two
channels
next we have data on serum samples that
were drawn at various days post SARS
cov2 RNA vaccination on the left we have
dual reporter results for iggpe and IGA
brilliant Violet 421 for nine replicate
reactions looking at the vaccine
response to the receptor binding domain
of the viral Spike one protein if you
compare the signal at Day Zero and day
24 post Stars cov2 vaccination shown by
this Black Arrow you can clearly see the
kinetics of antibody response in PCR
negative covid-19 naive individuals in
the center graph we compared the IGG
response against different SARS cov2
antigens here we're showing the receptor
binding domain or RBD of the spike
protein and the nucleic acid or n of the
virus and here you can easily
differentiate individuals who did not
have covid in the blue where we have
background signals on both antigens and
you can distinguish these from
individuals who are vaccinated with a
spike specific RNA vaccine in Black
where there's a high signal for RBD and
no signal for n and then you can
separate these as well from previously
infected individuals which are shown in
red where we have high signal for both
RBD and n Only infected individuals who
will have been exposed to M whereas
those vaccinated with a spike vaccine
will not
on the right we have antibody responses
over time which were measured in the
single reporter mode for antigen
specific IGA using all the classic xmap
instruments magpix luminex 200 and flex
map 3D and this was compared to the Dual
reporter mode on intelliflex I've not
discussed our magpix instrument with you
today but it uses magnetic bead capture
and imaging to measure the assays as
opposed to the flow-based analysis that
we use with the other instruments and
we're talking about today
so as shown here we saw a near perfect
correlation between the Dual reporter
readout using an anti-iga brilliant
Violet detection antibody compared to an
anti-igape labeled antibody on the other
x-map instruments and similar results
were also seen for specific IGG with all
the R square values at 0.98 for all
instances
here's some published work that came
from the University of Rochester that
was done using a three-plex serological
assay also for SARS cov2 but also Ace 2
was added as a competitor to serve as a
surrogate marker for potential
neutralizing antibody activity to SARS
cov2
on the left we have the antibody
response mfis and on the right we're
looking at the inhibition of antibody
binding when ace2 was added in a
competitive assay format the blue
shading shows the reporter 2 responses
measuring IGG and the orange shading
shows the reporter 1 IGM response the
green on the right panel is showing the
reactions that demonstrated a 30 or
greater binding inhibition with ace2
and so we can see the increase in
antibody signals over time from three
days of symptom onset shown in panel a
versus 12 days shown in panel C and 30
days shown in panel e and on the right
we see Ace two percent residual signals
at three days from symptom onset in
panel B 12 days in D and 30 days in F
this study and the protocol for this
assay was published in the Journal of
visualized experiments the citation is
down at the bottom of the slide so you
can actually see these results in much
more detail from the paper cited below
the tables and the links to this paper
are also available through the luminex
website so this is the first
peer-reviewed publication that was done
using the intelliflex instrument and the
Dual reporter mode
another publication from Rush University
shows the results of a dual reporter
assay measuring antibody isotypes also
for covid-19 that here they're
determining the specificity for the two
reporter channels after optimization of
primary standard and Sample
concentrations they optimize the
secondary antibody concentration and the
incubation times with this fully
optimized assay the authors assess the
specificity for the Dual Channel assays
as a result of the Dual Channel assay
format with one of each reporter
combination designated as the blank was
used to illustrate the lack of
cross-channel fluorescence or
interference which is what's shown in
the charts here the overall interference
was less than 6.5 percent but specific
interference depended on which antigen
and which antibody isotype was being
measured and thus the authors recommend
that one should determine the best
combinations to use for dual reporter
assays
in this case they suggest measuring IGM
with reporter 1 ficoerythrin and then
either IGG or IGA in the reporter 2
Channel with one of the Violet guys this
assay and the method was also published
and you can see this in more detail in
the paper cited at the bottom or through
the link to the same paper that's
available on the luminex website
in this figure from the same study they
measured zero conversion following
covid-19 vaccination plots illustrating
the relative titers to the spike antigen
during the course of vaccination are
shown here with IGG shown in the top in
panel a
IGM on the bottom left in B and IGA in C
on the bottom right the time measured
was from pre-vaccination to up to four
months post-completion and the time of
the vaccination is shown in days
relative to completion of the
vaccination series and the general time
points of the two vaccine dose
Administration are indicated in the
vertical dotted lines the experiments
were performed in the Dual Channel mode
and are described in much more detail in
the published protocol but you're able
to see that for you know multiple
patients and this is just showing four
of them you can definitely see the
antibody responses
um to all of the with all the different
isotypes that they're measuring
so now I've shown you several examples
of dual reporter immunoassays but you're
probably wondering well what about
nucleic acids because the same xmap
technology works great for both while
there's nothing published in the
peer-reviewed literature yet but I do
have some data to share with you that we
published in our xmap assay development
cookbook
on the left we had a duplex assay for
two different oligonucleotide targets
using our magplex tag microspheres each
Target was directly labeled with a
different reporter dot either Alexa 532
for the reporter one side or Alexa 405
for the reporter 2 Channel and what you
can see here is when we have both
targets and both reporters present in
the same reaction at the same time the
signal as shown by the solid lines is
equivalent to what we see when we only
had one Target and one reporter present
as shown by the dotted lines
on the right side we used Alexa 532 for
one target for the reporter one channel
and we used a biotinylated target with
streptavid and super bright 436 for the
second target for the reporter 2 Channel
and we have essentially the same results
whether we had one or both reporters
present as is shown by the dotted and
solid lines respectively and as you can
see I want to point out Alexa 532 is a
brighter die than Alexa 405 and we're
reaching about a 700 mfi versus only 150
mfi
but on the right you see that super
bright is much brighter at about 8 000
mfi versus the 700 of the Alexa 532 so
which combination of reporters that you
want to use really depends on the assay
so if I had one target that was
typically in a pretty high concentration
I would probably use the dimmer reporter
die for that one and then if I have a
Target that is usually low and very low
in concentration I would try to use the
brighter reporter for that one
note that for dual reporter assays at
least one of the detection reagents must
be directly conjugated to a reporter die
but then the other one can use a biotin
strep dividend reporter system
okay so here's some more nucleic acid
data and I'm showing you this because
while we looked at uh two Targets in a
two-plex in the same well and showed no
interference we wanted to have a model
system that would look at the
performance when we have both reporters
actually on the same molecule captured
onto the same bead and so this would
allow you to look at two similar targets
at the same time in a nucleic acid assay
say a pre messenger RNA versus a spliced
mature messenger RNA or like on the
protein side a post-translational
modification
so in this example you could have a
capture probe targeted to the same
shared sequence that would capture both
forms and then a detection reagent like
labeled complementary oligos that would
be specific for an intron and a splice
Junction that would be able to
differentiate the relative amounts of
the two species captured onto the same
bead so as a surrogate for that type of
measurement we developed an assay using
a DNA Target that has been dual labeled
with two reporter dots one is on the
five Prime end and the other is on the
three prime end
on the left we used a five Prime Alexa
532 for rp1 shown in Orange with a three
prime Biotin and streptavid and super
bright for rp2 shown in blue and again
we see no impact on the performance in
the Dual reporter system shown with the
solid lines as compared to the single
reporter measurements in the dotted
lines so now we're showing that you know
we have two reporters the two different
reporters very close together on the
same molecule and there's no
interference in the performance is the
same
on the right we saw similar results when
we put the rp2 reporter on the five
Prime end shown in blue And the rp1
reporter on the three prime ends shown
in Pink So based on these experiments we
find that the Dual reporter system will
work as well for nucleic acid assays as
it does with amino acids and it should
also work great for dual labels on the
same captured analyte Target
and with that I've come to the end of my
talk and so I'd like to thank you for
your attention today and if you have any
questions please put them into the chat
and I'll be happy to answer or get you
the answer if I don't know myself thank
you
thank you Sherry for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q a
portion of the webinar our first
question from our audience is what is
the highest Plex assay achieved for xmap
technology
well I happen to know that all 500 bead
sets have been used in assays at least
on the nucleic acid side there's a bunch
of research that comes from the broad
Institute and it's been published and
they're using all 500 bead sets to do a
gene expression profiling and looking at
a combinatorial chemistries for drug
work probably other applications as well
but that's the one that's like right on
the top of my mind and on the protein
side I know that at least about a 400
Plex is being used by multiple companies
and institutions in Europe particularly
when you're doing something that's a
serological application where you only
have one detection antibody say an
anti-ig specific antibody you could
totally
um do up to 500 Plex with with that type
of a combination and so I know that um
the kth in Stockholm Sweden is doing
really high Plex assays and the
oncommune in Germany is all also doing
at least 400 Plex assays
wonderful thank you so much the next
question from our audience is what are
some types of assays that can be used
with the Dual reporter
okay as I was mentioning I think this is
going to be really great for looking at
post-translational modifications
um such as methylation or
phosphorylation see having the Dual
reporter system would allow you to
measure the total amount of an analyte
that's present but with specific
detection reagents you could also
measure the specific sections that have
been modified and so we think that this
is going to be a really great
application for the Dual reporter system
wonderful thank you so much for your
answer it looks like we have time for
one more question that is are there
resources available to help with assay
development
oh that's really a great question well
I'm sure you don't want to spend time
going through 58 000 Publications but we
do have resources and we have our xmap
assay development cookbook we just
published the fifth edition in January
and it also includes some of these dual
reporter examples that I've shared with
you today in addition our Lumen explore
lab is a custom assay Development
Laboratory that's available at luminex
to help people who are developing assays
you know from Soup To Nuts really you
can start at the very beginning just
trying to get help with coming up with
your concept selecting your reagents
coupling QC I mean all the way from
beginning to end they're available to
help with that essay development work
fantastic thank you again Sherry for
your time today and your important
research before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions I'd like
to also thank our sponsors luminex a
dinosaur and Company for sponsoring
today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye